This is how the problem was set up for you. We have an array of elements, and
your job was to swap the first and the second half. I then move the j'th
position to the i'th position and then take the saved value in here. If
[UNKNOWN]
has reminded you how to swap two elements in an array, we've actually seen the
same thing with array lists before. Let's go through this really quickly so
that you understand this. So we want to swap these two positions. And in the
second line, it moves the j element into the i element thereby overwriting what
was in here. But fortunately in the first line we had moved that into the
variable saved. And then in the third line, we move it into j. Now we're ready
to apply the pseudo code that you've seen at the end of the previous unit.